انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
روسيا توجه رساله شديده اللهجه في بالي
واخرى اشد في كياب هجمات عنيفه تضرب
اوكرانيا وجارتيها بولندا
حرب اوكرانيا الاختبار الصعب في قمه
مجموعه العشرين القاده يحذرون من تكلفتها
الباهضه على اقتصاد العالم
الشارع الايرانيه يرفعوا مستوى العصيان
ويغير نهج الاحتجاج وتسريب يكشف عن تخطيط
النظام لحمله قمع اشد
بعد انفجار اسطنبول تركيا تحضر لعمليه في
شمال سوريا لملاحقه حزب العمال الكردستاني
وتتواعد بالقضاء على اي تهديدات
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه لم تسمع تحذيرات
قمه العشرين في بالي حول الحرب الروسيه
بقدر ما سمع اليوم صوت الصواريخ التي
امطرت مدن اوكرانيا وعاصمتها وجيرانها
ايضا حيث اتخذت الهجمات الروسيه منح
تصعيديا الان في ظل اتساع نطاق سقوط
الصواريخ الى بولندا
اكثر من 100 صاروخ ضربتها اليوم روسيا على
مختلف المدن الهجمات البنيه التحتيه
ومحطات الطاقه كالعاده لكن لم تسلم مرافق
حكوميه منها ايضا في نهج جديد للحرب
اذا اذا ما تحدثنا عن الاضرار داخل
اوكرانيا الطاقه خارجا وخدمه الانترنت
معطله والبلاد مظلمه
جراء الهجمات الروسيه فهل هي رساله من
موسكو في توقيت رفعت فيه كياب حده خطابها
امام قاده هات ال 20 في بالي ام رد واضح
على مبادره السلام التي يدفع الغرب
باتجاهها في الاونه الاخيره ام هي صفعه في
وجه مجموعه ال 20 كما قال الرئيس
الاوكراني بلودو ميرسي قبل قليل
اذا تاثير القصر الروسي امتدا لجيران
اوكرانيا اذا اعلن المتحدث باسم الحكومه
الفولنديه ان صواريخها روسيه اصابت منطقه
قريبه من الحدود مع اوكرانيا واصفرت عن
مقتل شخصين بولندا دعت الاجتماعي عاجل
للحكومه ولجنه الامن القومي والدفاع بعد
سقوط الصواريخ الروسيه القصف طالع ايضا
مولدوفا التي ابلغت عن انقطاعات هائله
للكهرباء في انحاء البلاد بعد هذه الغارات
الروسيه وقال وزير البنيه التحتيه في
مولدوفا اندريس ان همم بعد قصف روسيا
للنظام الطاقه الاوكرانيه انقطع احد خطوط
الطاقه الذي يؤمنوا انتقال الكهربائي الى
البلاد وادى ذلك الى انقطاعات هائله
للكهرباء في انحاء البلاد واشار الى ان
خطوط الطاقه التي سقطت لم تتضرر وان من
قطعت تلقائيا كاجراءا للامان
وفي تفاصيل الصواريخ الروسيه التي سقطت في
بولندا اشارت تقارير الى سقوط صاروخين هنا
في قريه بارزيدوف شمال شرق بولندا بالقرب
من الحدود مع اوكرانيا ما اسفر عن مقتل
شخصين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من جانبها نفذ
في تصريحات عاجله قبل قليل شلنا اي غارات
ضد اهداف قرب الحدود الاوكرانيه واضافت ان
الحديث عن سقوط الصواريخ في بولندا
متعمد يهدف لتصعيدي النساء هذا واظهرت
مقاطع فيديو تم تداولها عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي للاضرار التي تعرضت لها بولندا
بعد سقوط هذه الصواريخ الروسيه
تركيا تركيا
والمزيد من الاخبار العاجله روسيا تنفي
اذا انباء استهدافها
للاراضي البولنديه الدفاع الروسيه تقول
الحديث اذا عن سقوط صواريخ روسيه في
بولندا وهو استفزاز متعمد يهدف يهدف
لتصعيد النزاع اذا الان هناك مؤتمر صحفي
كذلك للخارجيه الامريكيه بانتظار ان يجهز
معنا اذا الخارجيه الامريكيه اذا تصدر
الموقفها اذا تقول نعمل مع بولندا لجمع
المعلومات وتقييم ما حدث في القريه
الحدوديه البولنديه الاوكرانيه وحقيقه اذن
هذه الصواريخ التي سقطت اذا نحن بانتظار
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي اذن للخارجيه
الامريكيه معنى للمزيد من وارسو العاصمه
الهولنديه اذن وسيم ابو حسن رئيس تحرير
موقع بولندا بالعربي مرحبا بكم معنا استاذ
وسيم ما المعلومات التي تمكنتهم من جمعها
حول هذه الصواريخ التي سقطت قرب الحدود
الاوكرانيه
نعم مساء الخير لحضرتك للصداقه المشاهدين
بالحقيقه رحنا حاليا بانتظار التصريح
الحكومي الرسمي حول ما حدث في المناطق
الحدود الحدوديه مع مع اوكرانيا منذ
تقريبا ساعه ونصف اجتمع مجلس الامن القومي
البولندي برئاسه الرئيس الجديد لمناقشه ما
حدث ولم يصدر تاكيد حتى اللحظه من الحكومه
البولنديه ان كانت هذه الصواريخ روسيه او
قادمه من جهه اخرى غير معلومات ف نحن
بانتظار هذه المعلومات الاوليه ان تشير
الى سقوط صاروخين مجهولين حتى اللحظه من
الحكومه لم تؤكد ادى الى مقتل شخصين
الصواريخ سقطت في منطقه شوف تحديدا وقعت
في منطقه زراعيه احدها احد الصواريخ
زراعي في خلال عمل الاشخاص الموجودين ضمن
المنطقه الزراعيه على هذا الجرار فيما سقط
الصاروخ الاخر في منطقه قريبه منه على
مبنى سكني ادى الى سقوط الضحيه الثانيه
هذه هي المعلومات الحاليه كما قلنا نحن
بانتظار التاكيد الحكومي لمصدر هذه
الصواريخ
المعتصممها تشير الى قادمه من الجانب
الاوكراني وسقطت داخل الاراضي البولنديه
نعم طيب همم فيما يتعلق بالوضعيه بولندا
خلال هذه الحرب كانت هناك حاله ترقب وخشيه
من ان تمتد الحرب في اوكرانيا الى اراضيها
هل برايك نحن في وارد ان يحدث هذا الان في
هذه المرحله ام ربما سيكون هناك حديث على
انه صواريخ ربما سقطت بالخطا
فالحقيقه كما هو معلوم لجميع المتابعين
للحرب في اوكرانيا منذ بدايتها بولندا
كانت راس الحربه فيما يحصل في اوكرانيا
كانت الجهه الاولى لارسال المساعدات
العسكريه لجاره الاوكراني اضافه للدعم
السياسي وغيرها من الخطوات التي قامت بها
بولندا على الناحيه الاخرى كانت هولندا
تسعى بشكل سريع الى تقويه المخزون العسكري
الخاصه
وغيرها من الطائرات والمعدات العسكريه
استعدادا لمثل هذا الموقف بحسب التسريبات
حتى اللحظه فان الاجتماع الذي يدور حاليا
شارك فيه مسؤولين من حلف الناتو اذا اضافه
الى وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه لاطلاعهم
على المعلومات والتخطيط والتنسيق في ما
بينهم لاتخاذ الخطوات القادمه من غير
المتوقع
مرور الكرام بالنسبه لهولندا دائما
هي عضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي واذا استهدف
اي بلد عضو
ان ال ال الحلف يتدخل همم لو ثبت ان هذين
الصاروخين هما بالفعل اطلقتهما روسيا على
الاراضي البولنديه ماذا سيحدث
بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه بانها سوف تطلب
بتفعيل الماده الخامسه من اتفاقيه حلف
الناتو لحمايه اراضيها وكما قلنا سبق هذا
عدد عده خطوات امها زياده التعداد القوات
الامريكيه الموجوده في بولندا وتعزيز
الجناح الشرقي
بارسال وحدات عسكريه ايضا الى الاراضي
البولنديه فكما قلنا بولندا كانت مستعده
لهذا النوع من التصعيد وبانتظار حاليا
الخطوات التي ستقوم بها او يستطيع عنها
الحكومه بعد انتهاء هذا الاجتماع
الينا الان في هذه الساعه مراسله العربيه
من موسكو كاتيا طعمه ومن كيف كذلك حذيفه
همم عادل همم اذا الخارجيه الامريكيه في
هذا الخبر العاجل تقول للتقارير من بولندا
مقلق للغايه الخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد كذلك
نعمل مع الشركاء بشان التقارير التي تتحدث
عن الصواريخ روسيه في همم بولندا اذا
كافيا اسالك همم ماذا قالت موسكو عن حقيقه
هذه الصواريخ التي يقال انها روسيه
واستهدفت الارض هولنديه
مرحبا صهيب بالفعل الدفاع الروسيه منذ
قليل نفذ جمله وتفصيلا جميع ما اعتبرته
ماذا عن بشان قصف اهداف قرب الحدود
البولنديه الاوكرانيه واعتبرته طبعا
بمثابه استفزاز متعمد لتصعيد الموقف من
قبل وسائل الاعلام الهولنديه ولفت طبعا
جميع انه جميع الصور التي تم نشرها همم من
قبل الوسائل الاعلام البولنديه انها تعود
الى حطام صواريخ لاسلحه روسيه همم طبعا
تاكدت ان هذه الصواريخ ليست روسيه لم تقم
اليوم بقتل مواقع باجانب الحدود الاخرانيه
البولنديه مع العلم صهيب ان اليوم كان
هناك تكثيف من قبل الجانب الروسي لقصف
مواقع اوكرانيه في كامل انحاء همم
اوكرانيا وسائل الاعلام روسيه تحدثت ان
الحصان قد يعود الى صواريخ تعود الى
اوكرانيا صواريخ اوكرانيه
في جمله وتفصيلا انها تكون استهدفت
الاراضي البولنديه بولندا العضو في حلف
شمال الاطلسي ااا دعونا نتحول الى كيف
حذيفه انت معنا ماذا تقول كياف
نعم تحيات اسرائيل في الحقيقه كيف تقول ان
الحرب تخطط الحدود الاوكرانيه الى حدود
حلف الناتو وعدد من المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
على سبيل المثال الاندرير ماكا رئيس مكتب
ديوان الرئاسه الاوكراني قال قلت لكم في
تصريح يعني قال قلت لكم ان الحرب ستعد
ستعدى حدود اوكرانيا ايضا ارسل التعازي
الى الاشقاء البولنديين وقال ان الان الحر
تتعدى حدود اوكرانيا
وبوتن لم يتوقف عند حدود اوكرانيا اه طبعا
هنالك ايضا حمله التضامن واسعه على مواقع
التواصل على اجتماعي حمل التضامن شعبيه
الاوكرانيين مع الاشقاء الهولنديين دائما
يصرفون بالاشقاء طبعا تعلم موقف بولندا من
الحرب الاوكرانيه والمساعدات الكبيره التي
تلقتها اوكرانيا من البولندي
اوكرانيا بشكل عام هنالك حمله التضامن من
المسؤولين وايضا على المستوى الشعبي
طيب اعود الى ضيفي في وارسو استاذ وسيم
واسالك كذلك عن هذا النفي الروسي واتهامها
بان الحديث عن سقوط صواريخ روسيه في
بولندا استفزازي وهدفه توسيع دائره هذه
الحرب
لكن سبق في اكثر من حادثه خلال
اشهر الحرب الاوكرانيه بان وصلت الصواريخ
الروسيه الى المناطق الحدوديه وفي احد
المرات وصلت الى بعد ثلاثه واربعه
كيلومترات فقط من المرشح جدا ان تكون هذه
الصواريخ الروسيه الصواريخ التي سقطت في
الاراضي البولنديه هي صواريخ روسيه لكن
يبقى السؤال هنا هل هي فعلا متعمده
الانسان هذه الصواريخ وايصالها الى داخل
الحدود البولنديه اما هي وصلت عن طريق
الخطا كما قلنا يعني نحن بانتظار فقط
تاكيد من الجانب الحكوميه او وجهه نظرهم
لما حدث الان والخطوه القادمه التي سوف
يتم اتخاذه التي على الاغلب ستكون
الصعيديه تجاه روسيا خصوصا وانا كمان كما
تشير المعلومات الى سقوط ضحيتين حتى
اللحظه لا نعلم ان كان العدد سيرتفع لا
لكن مجرد سقوط ضحايا سوف يدفع المجتمع
البولندي والشارع البولندي والحكومه
الهولنديه التي خطوات صعيديه على العموم
حتى الامريكيون ما زالوا همم يعني يدرسون
الوضع الامريكي تقول انها طلعت على
التقارير الوارده اذا من بولندا وستحدد
الخطوات التاليه
المناسبه المتحدثه باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي قالت ان واشنطن اذن اطلعت على
هذه التقارير من بولندا حول سقوط صواريخ
روسيه على اراضيها واضافت على تويتر
بلادها تعمل مع الحكومه البولنديه لجمع
المزيد من
المعلومات معنى من كيف الان السيد بلودمي
شوماكو
همم سيدمر اهلا بكم معنا حديث عن صواريخ
روسيه تسقط في بولندا ما قد يوسع دائره
هذه الحرب لانها تستهدف احد دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي بينما روسيا تنفي هذا تنفي
مسؤوليتها عن هذا القصف وتقول انه هدفه
التصعيد والاستفزاز ما تعليقك
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته وعليكم
السلام
هذه الكارثه حدثت بسبب سياسه ارهابيه
روسيه معروف بان اليوم روسيا اطلقت 90
صاروخا الى اوكرانيا كمان
ونحن كمان هنا في اوكرانيا
بولنديه او روسيا يستهدفت عرض اراضي
بوليديه همم عميده يعني ولكن هذا او هذا
الشيء من الضروري بان سوف يكون تحقيق
الدول في اقرب وقت لكي ان نعرف بالضبط هل
هل روسيا يستهدفت هذه الاراضي همم بولنديه
تونسيه بشكل
عام مباشر او هذه الشوفايه من
في خروسيه التي همم التي استهدفت قوات
مصالحه اوكرانيه نعم طيب اا اعود الى
مراسلتنا في موسكو
كاتيا واسالك هل هناك اي تعليق من الكريم
او اي مسؤولين روسيين همم اذا ما كان ربما
هذه الصواريخ سقطت عن طريق الخطا في
الاراضي
البولنديه ام لا
حتى الان صهيب هو من الدفاع الروسيه
تماما ان يكون هناك او ان يكون هناك سقوط
عن طريق الخطا اللي صواريخ روسيه الكريمي
طبعا حتى الان لم يعلق على هذه همم هذا
الوضع حتى الان ولكن الدفاع اكدت ان هذه
الصواريخ هي لا تعود الى الاسلحه الروسيه
وانه لم يتم قصف مواقع خلال عمليه القصف
المكثفه التي شاهدناها اليوم ذكيه جميع
اراضي الاخرانيه لم يكن هناك استهداف له
مناطق حدوديه اسلاميه بولنديه من الجانب
الروسيه
يعني في اي سياق تضعون ذكرتهم ان هناك
اليوم 90 صاروخا روسيه سقطت على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وحدها ام همم لو نحاول ان نفهم
سياق هذا التصعيد في وقت كنا بالامس نتحدث
ربما عن فرص لاحلال السلام فرص بدء
مفاوضات بدعم غربي همم كذلك مفاوضات سلام
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا فهمم في اي سياق يمكن
وضع هذا التصعيد العسكري اليوم
همم
حول روسيا وبولندا اكيد همم دعايه روسيه
هي سوف تنفق كل شيء يعني حتى
عندما روسيا الجماعيه في منطقه
روسيا ايضا
في حاله مع بولندا وكمان يعني الواحد
يجهده بان بصفه عامه همم
يعني من جانب واحد وهو يطلب المفاوضات من
جانب ثاني شيء وهو يقصف اوكرانيا بشكل
عنيف هذا بصراحه اجبار
للمفاوضات مش اجبار ل استسلام مفوت انه
يعتذر يعني بعض لهذا القصف عينيه سوف يكون
استسلامه او من الممكن هذا انتقام للشعب
الاوكراني يعني كل حال همم النظام بوتين
يرتك بوجه مرحبا ومن الضروري بان سلطه
روسيه سوف تحاسب امام المحكمه الجنائيه
على كل جرائم التي روسيا ترتقي به هنا في
اوكرانيا نعم اذا مشاهدينا من التحق بنا
الان نذكركم بهذا الخبر الذي نتابعه في
اخبار الساعه هذا المساء صاروخان يعتقد
انهما روسيان سقط على الاراضي البولنديه
على الحدود مع اوكرانيا هناك همم اجتماع
كذلك همم في مجلس الامن القومي البولندي
وكذلك اجتماعات كذلك مع النيته باعتبار ان
بولندا همم دوله عضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي
والسياسه الدفاعيه للحرف تقتضي اذا تعرضت
اي دوله لهجوم فان الحلف عليه ان همم يرد
كذلك الولايات المتحده قالت انها تدرس هذه
التقارير وتتشاور مع البولنديين حول حقيقه
اذا كانت هذه الصواريخ
روسيه سقطت في الاراضي ال- همم بولنديه
يلتحق بنا الان من موسكو الدبلوما السابق
ما توصف سيد متوظف اهلا بك معنا في اخبار
الساعه هل تريد روسيا حربا عالميا من خلال
استهداف بولندا كما يتهممها الغرب
هذا قصه مضحكه
همم هذا الذي ارتكب الغلطه او تحدي
الاستفزازه واكرهيني 100%
مش روسيه تحكي كيكات وواجده ان كل هذا
الصاروخين
يتساقطه في الرابطونيه في مركز الزراعه
الزراعي بجمع القمح تم- قتلوا اثنين من
همم
البولونيين كانت هناك بقايا من الصاروخ
واقرايني بقايا من صاروخ مضاد لصواريخ
ولي- همم 300 نعم ولذلك امريكا
او تحدي او استفزاز اوكراني لكي يجر
ناتو الى حرب مع الروشه ابشر يا شباب هذا
ليست القصه الذي يمكن على هذه الطريقه
تورط الغرب لمواجهه همم هناك الان حتى
واشنطن على مستويات مختلفه من فائده
مع روسيا انتم ترفضوا مش انتم وهذه
المسرحيه بين انه المسرح اليوم على قياده
اخرىنيه
هذا هو ينتشر الى تلك العمليه
اذا كنت فهمتك بشكل جيد انت تقول انه
الصاروخين الذين سقط على الاراضي
البولنديه هم صاروخان اوكرانيات اوكرانيا
اطلقتهما عمدا عمدا كي تورط روسيا يعني
مش انا اقوله هذا التحقيقات كانت جاره من
جانب امريكي ومن جانب بولوني ان هناك
بقايا الاقسام الصواريخ اس 3
وغير مثيره هذا هو الان وجدوا بقايا اقسام
من هذه الصواريخ
وارد ضيفه
كيف ترد علي السيد الذي يقول انه هذه يعني
مسرحيه وان اوكرانيا تريد روسيا همم من
خلال استهداف الاراضي الفولنديه لانها
تعلم جيدا ان هذا سيوسع دائره الصراع
بدخول حلف شمال الاطلسي
قولنا اليوم روسيا تصفيات ويستهدفت بنيه
تغطيه حضاريه في مدينه تيرنوبل هذا غرب
اوكرانيا بالمناسبه هذا الثانيه
اوكرانيا غير مجنونه لتحقيق استفزازات على
الاراضي بولنديه حليفه اوكرانيه
اما حطت نوويه
عدد كبير من الاستفزازات وحتى ابتزازات
سوف تكون على كل حال يا تحقيق
امريكي بولندي
اكيد وبعدين سوف
الصاروخ روسي
صواريخ روسيا نحن بصراحه
ممكن كانت استفزازات
روسيه روسيا طارق بن طارق ما ما هو سوف
يكون الرابط من ناطور يعني لو سلمنا جدنا
بهذه الفرضيه سيد شوماكوف لو كانت روسيا
وراء استهداف الاراضي البولنديه الى ما
تهدف ما الهدف
بصفه عامه
من الصواريخ الروسيه
الاولى بصراحه نعم استمعنا الى وجهتين
نظركما ان وجهه النظر الاوكرانيه والروسيه
دعونا نذهب الى وجهه نظر اصحاب الشان في
بولندا همم سيد وسيم اذا كنت متزال معي
استمعت الى ما قاله ضيفي السيد شو ماكو
همم ضيف الاوكرانيا يقول انه اوكرانيا
ليست مجنونه كي تستهدف الاراضي همم
البولنديه وضيف الروسي يقول انها مسرحيه
اوكرانيه من اجل توسيع دائره هذه الحرب ما
رايك
بعد ما اتفق اكيد مع الضيف الاوكراني يعني
حتى لو تحدثنا عن موضوع غير موضوع
الصاروخين اليوم السياسه الروسيه تجاه
بولندا هي سياسه استفزاز منذ بدايه الحرب
مع اوكرانيا مع محاوله جرها لي تصعيد
عسكري الى نوع مع بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه
فالحديث عن تصليح على سبيل المثال اقليم
جراد الجيب الروسي الموجود على الحدود
البولنديه اضافه الى الحديث عن النقل
المهاجرين غير الشرعيه الى تلك المنطقه
ايضا بهدف ادخالهم الى بولندا واحداث ازمه
سياسيه في الداخل الحديث ايضا عن
نيه روسيا استهداف اي قواف العسكريه
ترسلها قوات النادره
يقول انه همم الصاروخين لم يستهدف اي
مواقع عسكريه او يعني استراتيجيه هما
سقطاه يعني القتيلان هما مزارعان سقطاه في
همم همم حقول للقمح
هو نفس السياسه المتبعه حاليا في اوكرانيا
فروسيا في اوكرانيا تستهدف حتى البنيه
التحتيه بهدف الترويع وتخويف المواطنين
وتدمير البنيه التحتيه الصاروخان
ربهم هما محاوله اخافه بولندا طبعا في حال
ثبتت التحقيقات انها صواريخ روسيه سيكون
السبب المؤكد ان محاوله للضغط على الحكومه
الهولنديه وتخويف المجتمع البولندي الذي
كان منذ اللحظه الاولى
للمجتمع الاوكراني والجيش الاوكراني عبر
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه والعسكريه
وغيرها من الخطوات الدبلوماسيه التي قامت
بها بولندا منذ اليوم الاول للحرب الروسيه
في موسكو لاسالك كذلك على السياق ما يحدث
الان همم الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي وضعه في سياق انه صفعه
لقمه العشرين هل هذا التصعيد الروسي هو رد
على الغرب وعدم التوافق والرغبه في يعني
محاصره روسيا في قمه مجموعه العشرين في
بالي
انتم تعني هذا الحدث في بولونيا او قرارات
جويه الروسيه على مناطق مختلفه على ارادو
كرينيه
التردد الفعل الروسي من تصريح
يعني بالنسبه لي صواريخ مضاده للصواريخ
اوكرانيا
سلاح موجود
هذا الغاره مكثفه كما يعتبرون عندنا الان
الغاره اكثر من 100 الصاروخ من قليبر من
بحر ومن تايرات استراتيجيه توبوليفيد 95
وكذلك
بطيرات مسيره ضربوا اكثر من 100 صاروخ على
همم حوالي 80 الهدف دمروا في كل الاراضي
اوكرانيه بدايه
يعني هو يتحدث عن الصفحه لمجموعه العشرين
عن التصعيد الروسي هذا عن هذه يعني عشرات
الصواريخ اللي تتحدث عن 100 صاروخ ولكن
هذا يدفعني كي اتساءل الا يعقل انه من
المئه صاروخ التي سقطت اليوم على اوكرانيا
ان يكون هذان الصاروخان سقط بالخطا في
الاراضي البولنديه
انا قلت انا صاروخ الذي اطلق الروس روسيا
صاروخ على هذا اقسام الصاروخ سقط في في
هولندا بولونيا اااا هذا الصاروخ مضاد
لطيران الصواريخ يعني
طيب
وهذا موجوده في انترنت
التقارب والصور فوتوغرافيه كاس اقسام
وبقايا من هذا الشروق
مشاهدين الكرام المزيد من المواقف الان
بلجيكا تدين سقوط صواريخ روسيا على بولندا
وتؤكد تضامنها مع وارسو خبر الساعه اذا
قتيلان بولنديان من المزارعين في سقوط
صاروخين روسيين يعتقد انهما روسيان اذا
حسبتهامات الاوكرانيين وكذلك البولنديين
في انتظار نتائج التحقيقات هناك اجتماعات
اذن الان في حلف شمال الاطلسي لبحث حقيقه
همم هذين الصاروخين لان هذا سيوسع مدى هذه
الحرب دعونا نستمع الان همم الى ما قاله
الرئيس في الاردن على هذه الهجمات الروسيه
حيث طلب الرئيس في الاردن
تحسبا لاي ضربات روسيه اضافيه
بسم الله
85 ضربه صاروخيه على اوكرانيا وعلى مدننا
في الغالب على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه من
الواضح هذا ما يريده العدو ولن يحققه
هدفهما ربما لا تنزله هناك ضربات في
المستقبل لذلك اطلب من الجميع توخي الحذر
والبقاء في الفتره من الوقت اعلم ان
الضربات قطعت امدادات الكهرباء عن العديد
من المدن في بلدنا نحن نعمل وسوف نستعيد
كل شيء وسوف ننجو من كل شيء
نتابع المشهد مباشره مع مراسلنا في كياب
حذيفه اذا نتحدث عن الصاروخان الذين سقط
في بولندا لكن هناك عشرات غيرها من
الصواريخ سقرت في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
اليوم على اسفلت
نعم
اعود الى الرئيس الذي
علق على هذه الحادثه وعلى سقوط صاروخين في
دوله بولندا في منطقه قريبه من الحدود
الاوكرانيه وقال حدث مع حذرت منه اوكرانيا
كثيرا وهو ان الارهاب الروسي لن يتوقف عند
اوكرانيا وانما سيزحف نحو حلف انيته وقال
يعني ادعوا يعني اقول للاشقاء البولنديين
ان اوكرانيا معكم وادعونا نعمل معا جميعا
لانهاء الارهاب الروسي وان نفعل كل شيء عن
هذا همم
كذلك رئيس ديوان الرئاسه الاوكراني ايضا
علق على الحادثه وقالت لكم من قبل انهم لم
يفكرون حتى في التوقف عند الحدود
الاوكرانيه كذلك عدد من المسؤولين
الاخرانيين علقوا عن الحديث عن 100 صاروخ
اطلق على 17 ولايه خمسه عشره
تضررت بشكل كبير وانقطعت الكهرباء في معظم
الولايات الاخرانيه عاده الان الى
تحديدا عدد اليها الكهرباء ولكن 90% من
منطقه الفوف وهي مقطوعه الكهرباء والدنبرا
بتروفس 80 في المئه وخارقه بالكامل قطعت
عنها الكوره وعدد كبير من احياء العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف طبعا قتل شخص في العاصمه
واصيب اخرين هنا في العاصمه طبعا نتيجه
هذه الضربه التي استهدفت معظم الولايات
الاخرانيه ما زالت السلطات تطالب المدنيين
بان يتعاملوا بجديه مع الانذارات الجويه
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا الحديث مباشره
واعود الى مراسلتنا في موسكو كاتيا تعني
هل هناك اي همم مواقف او تصريحات همم
جديده همم وفيما يتعلق كذلك هذا التصعيد
العسكري همم الروسي يتزمن كذلك مع مغادره
الرئيس همم الوزير
لقمه ال 20 همم في همم بالي همم هل هناك
يعني اي ربط او اي يعني حديث على
اهداف هذا التصعيد الروسي
ات الكريمه التي علقت على تصريحات رئيس
الاوكراني الذي رفض اجراء اي او امكانيه
عقد اي محادثات مع اجانب روسي الذي قال
انهم ينعدم لا يوجد اي امكانيه لحدوث من
ثلاثه همم وعلق عليها اليوم الذي طبعا اكد
ان اوكرانيا لا تريد اتفاوض مع روسيا وان
روسيا طبعا لن تقبل باي شروط
لي الدخول الى المحادثات همم ومن بعد ذلك
اتت هذه طبعا همم اتى هذا التصعيد المكثف
من قبل الاجانب الروسي الذي طبعا لم يتم
التحديث او التحدث عنه حتى الان من قبل
الكرم شكرا جزيلا لك طعم اذن مباشره من
موسكو
اليك في همم موسكو كذلك لاسالك هل هذا
التصعيد غير الصاروخين اللذان سقط في
بولندا لا نعلم بعده مكان همم روسيان كما
تتهم بعض الاطراف او كما تقول انت انهما
اوكرانيات ولكن التصعيد في اوكرانيا اليوم
هل هو الرد الروسي على دعوات الحوار
والمفاوضات بين الاوكرانيين والروس
بعض التسريبيه بيان الكاشي من قبل على
شاشه التلفزيون في خدمه 20 لا شك ان هذا
همم
فكره واضحه بنسبه لروسيا لقياده الروسيه
وين هو الموقف الحقيقي شو اهداف الحقيقيه
في اوكرانيا
انه امريكا ورقه كل القرارات وكرانيه مين
البيان من قبل همم الرئيس
مستعيده ولكن يا ده اليسرى لنفس همم
الابار الامريكيه تعطيه اشارات معينه
لسلطه اوكرانيه ولذلك هناك بوليسيه
وبوليسي طيب يعني واحد يتكلم بلغه السلام
واحد ثاني يرفض لغه الصلاه
انت تقصد باليد اليمنى واليد اليسرى يعني
تقصد اليد اليمنى الامريكيين واليد اليسرى
تقسيط الاوكرانيين ام تقصد طرفا اخر في
الاداره الامريكيه
لا انا تعبر ان انا رايي الشخصي انا نفس
توسيع الادوار
ولكن هذا طالع الشاشه مو عادي لروسيا
لا يسمحوا اييي مخرج الروسيا من تلك
الورده الذي كانت يدبرون
ان يرقي اوكرانيا وفي الوكلاء
الضربه كاشيه على الاعتراف
من موسكو وكذلك ضيفي من كياب السيد شوماكو
همم سنستكمل مشاهدينا تغطيه خبر الساعه
صاروخاني يعتقد انهما روسيان سقط في
الاراضي البولنديه العضو في حلف شمال
الاطلسي ما قد يندر بتوسيع دائره هذه
الحرب بتدخل نستكمل التغطيه بعد تفاصيل
قصيره معنا
مرحبا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا ان نذكر بخبر
الساعه اذا صواريخ الروسيه التي سقطت على
بولندا اشارت تقارير الى سقوط صاروخين في
قريه بريزيدوف شرق بولندا بالقرب من
الحدود مع اوكرانيا ما اسفر عن مقتل شخصين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من جانبها النفث في
تصريحات عاجله قبل قليل شلنا اي غارات ضد
اهداف قرب الحدود الفولولنديه الاخرانيه
واضافت ان الحديث عن سقوط الصواريخ في
بولندا واستفزاز متعمد يهدف لتصعيد النساء
اذا اعود الى ضيوفي واعد هذه المره الى
ضيفه من وارسو وسيم ابو حسن رئيس تحرير
موقع بولندا بالعربي همم اعود اليك سيد
وسيم هل صدرت اي ما يعني تعليقات او اي
مواقف جديده من وارسو او من حلف شمال
الاطلسي وماذا نعرف عن المنطقه التي سقط
فيها الصاروخان اللذان يعتقد انه روسيا
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك استاذ المشاهدين مره
اخرى حتى اللحظه لم ينتهي الاجتماع الخاص
بالحكومه والمجلس الامن القومي البولندي
لكن المعلومه الاضافيه التي تم تناولها
نقدا عن شهود عيان من المنطقه التي تم
سقوط الصواريخ فيها هي انه تاكيد سقوط
ضحيه واحده حتى اللحظه في ما عمليات البحث
مستمره لايجاد الشخص الثاني الذي يعتبر
مختفي حتى اللحظه ولا يمكن تاكيد همم
وفاته بسبب الاستهداف الصاروقي المنطقه
التي تم استهدافه هي منطقه حدوديه تبعد عن
الحدود الاخرانيه مسافه تقل عن 10 كيلو
مترات وهي احد مناطق تجمع ايضا سابقا احد
مناطق تجمع اللاجئين الاوكرانيهم الى
اماكن اخرى اضافه الى انها قريبا نوع من
قواعد عسكريه بتبعد عنها بحدود ال 10 الى
15 كلم هولندي الى شمال
عدد من عدد من القوات الامريكيه المتواجده
في المنطقه خطه الناتو لحمايه الجناح
الشرقي للبلاد نعم طيب ما رايك في ما قاله
ضيفي قبل قليل من موسكو السيد فشلوف ما
توظف بان الصاروخان هما من طراز اس 300
والذين تستخدمهما اوكرانيا للدفاع الجوي
ما ينفي تماما ان تكون روسيا قد وصلت الى
الاراضي البولنديه ويعني هذا يعني مؤشر
صريحه لان اوكرانيا كما قال ضيفي من موسكو
بانها تريد توريط روسيا
تو هولندا سابقا برد صارم وحازم نتيجه
لدعم هذه اوكرانيا منذ اليوم الاول للحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وكما قلنا ايضا
الصواريخ الروسيه وصلت بالفعل سابقا الى
مناطق قريبه جدا من المناطق الحدوديه
البولنديه والتصعيد كان مستمر بين
الجانبين منذ بدايه اليوم الاول فقد تكون
نعم ربما تكون هذه الصواريخ اوكرانيه لكن
حتى لو كانت الصواريخ التي سقطت فيها صوا
ريخ بات جويه اوكرانيه اطلقت لاسقاط
الصواريخ الروسيه فان روسيا لا تزال تتحمل
جزء من المسؤوليات سقوط هذه الصواريخ
ووصول اشلاء منها على الاقل ان الاراضي
الاوكراني البولنديه والسقوط ضحايا
والمجتمع البولندي كما قلنا لديه اساسا
حساسين مما يحدث والضغط سوف يكون كبيرا
على الحكومه لاتخاذ موقف صار من- من هذه
الفتره خبر عاجل الان على الشاشه مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني ضربت الروسيه على بولندا
ليست حادثا بل هي رساله متعمده من موسكو
اذن مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني يعتبر همم ان
همم هذا الصاروخان هما روسيا بالفعل
بانهما ليس همم عن طريق الخطا وهي رساله
متعمده من موسكو وكاله الانباء الفولوديه
تقول ان اجتماع لجنه الامن والدفاع برئاسه
رئيس الحكومه اذا المستمر كما قال ضيف
الاستاذ وسيم من وارثه اذا قبل قليل في
انتظار ان ترشح اي معلومات حول هذا
الاجتماع كذلك الامريكيون هم يراقبون
الوضع ويتابعون التقارير همم كذلك همم حول
همم حقيقه هاذين الصاروخين اذا كانت روسيه
ام لا اعود الى ضيفي من كيف فلودومير شو
ماكو ضد خماسيه السابق سيد فلودومير اذا
ما ثبت ان الصاروخان هما صاروخان روسيان
استهدفا بولندا الدوله في حلف شمال
الاطلسي ماذا سيحدث
انا
مثل الشديد همم
جوهريه بالمناسبه الروسيه تقصف مدن
اوكرانيه وخاصه
هناك عدد كبير من الشذائيه فيها وهذا كمان
جرائم حرب هو هذا معروف وهنا في القران
يعني علاوه لا هذا روسيا اليوم قصفت بشكل
عنيف همم اوكراني هي اطلقت 9:30 وكمان هي
استهدفت
يعني هذا قريبه منه حدود وكان يعني انا
لكن من الممكن اولا هذا استفزازات روسيه
او هذا الشي روايه
روسي
دائما ترتكبه استفزا المنطقه مختلفه همم
سيد همم ما توظف في موسكو هل تعتقد ان
حلفنيته حتى لو ثبت ان هذين الصاروخان هما
روسيان وسقط في الاراضي الفولانديه في
دوله عضو في الناتو فانه لن يرد ردا
عسكريا على روسيا
يرد على كل التحدي وهذا حسب الدستور حلف
الشمال
خامسه لازم يتورط هذا هو كانت هدف جلنسكي
الذي كان يحب بعض هذه الدرب اليوم
اوكرانيا في كل مدن اساسيه واقرانيه مره
وتستمر بري انا هذا الليل كذلك
ولكن في هذه الحاله هم بحاجه
التورته الى هذا المعركه
يفقدون اشياء كثيره
لكن التصعيد كبير اليوم كذلك في اوكرانيا
من قبل الجيش الروسي هل ماتت اي فرصه
لمفاوضات السلام
الروسيا مفتوحه لمفاوضات السلام
وافكارها حول موقف السياسي هذا السياسي
اللي روشه
نقلوا الى قلابه وزير الخارجيه اوكرانيوتي
في شهر ابريل في اسطنبول شخصيه
ولذلك لحتى الان شروط علاج الرده فيها همم
عبر شاشه تليفزيون يعطيه 20 سنه
لا شايف تقول انهم يقترحون همم
يعترفوا هزيمه استسلام الروسي مطلق
وانسحاب مطلق منكولا اراضي بما فيها ترم
وطبعا هذا جواب على اقتراحات روسيه واضحه
وسط بعض ليست اشهر
هذا هو جواب ولذلك روشك برؤيه قررت ان
يتابعوا الحرب بكل الامكانيات عسكريه
الموجوده
اللي هذا يح
وعلى السكان اذا كانت بمكان همم روشه
اميركا
تقول المدن الاقي فيها
الاصدار الاوامر كيف حالك طيب
مشاهدينا تذكير سريع خبر الساعه هذه
الليله سقوط صاروخان ويعتقد انهما روسيا
على الاراضي البولنديه بولندا الدوله
العضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي النيتمازال
يدرس الوضع معلومات عن سقوط قتيلين
بولنديين في هذين بينما روسيا تنفي تماما
ان تكون قد اطلقت اي صواريخ على الاراضي
البولنديه تبعنا معكم من موسكو ومنك
واشكركم شكرا جزيلا لضيوف الكرام من موسكو
الدبلوماسيه السابقه
كيف كذلك قد خماسيه الاوكراني
وسيم ابو حسن رئيس تحرير موقع بولندا
بالعربي
ادينا فاصل بعده موجز والرياض
ه اخبار الساعه كان الخبر الرئيس اذا
بولندا الى اللقاء